The Long Term Plan or LTP may sound...a
tad boring but it's so important
for Waimakariri because it helps define how we're
going to grow and the rates we're going to pay.
Dan, I can't believe you're in
the same park at the same time!
John, I can't believe I've seen you here,
in fact I've never seen you
before, it's lovely to meet you!
Well listen, as a stranger, LTP?
Yeah, so we're coming into Council's Long
Term Plan, so basically it's our budget
and so the things that we're looking at is the
sort of growth that we've got in our district,
the sort of needs that we have and
how we're going to pay for them.
The LTP budgets for the Council's critical work:
roads pipes and rubbish collection but also
places that provide a sense of community
such as libraries, pools, parks and of course
sports facilities.
So each LTP is a balancing act
between what the District needs,
what the residents want and
what the Council can afford.
So if there's something the public
want the Council to do or indeed
don't want the Council to do?
Now's the time to tell us.
To find out more visit
waimakariri.govt.nz/letstalk